what do you think what what is your
opinion
on like all of the stuff you see online
today nowadays everybody has a phone you
all you see is like shootings with kids
getting shot everywhere and
all the stuff with the guy got who just
got murdered george floyd and like
all all the stuff that's going on with
police brutality in the news today
and compared to what it was like when
you were running the streets of new york
like what is your
this is [ __ ] disneyland
what do you mean by that this is
disneyland compared to what it was back
then
right yeah this is a [ __ ] joke
there's no brutality out there today and
if there is it seems like
most of the time it's captured on
there's somebody with a phone who's
filming it yeah
you see every [ __ ] incident today
back then there was one every
three minutes and
you know i spent the last two weeks with
a bunch of rap guys i can't repeat i
don't know names
i was with these bunch of rappers and
they were all from in my era you know
i was chasing them down the street
because they were selling crackers
and rapping songs on weekends you know
and then so but half these guys i ended
up running into
and uh they were like it was so much
better back in the 80s and 90s today
[ __ ] it's crazy out there you know
because they got their beating they got
their money taken they went home
right and they could keep running their
business they could keep doing their
[ __ ] thing you know
this is them this is them telling me i'm
the cop in the room we're doing a
podcast with a bunch of guys smoking
ganja over my head and [ __ ] running
around
you know blood clot [ __ ] and
and and and
this is how they this is how they uh
they're telling me jesus it was so much
better you guys were way better back
then
today everybody gets locked up for
nothing you know so i mean this is this
is the guys who took beatens all their
life but they
but they were out the next day and they
were living a life and
they weren't telling on the police and
the police weren't telling on them it
was just
it was a whole different society back
then you know the 80s destroyed a lot of
people's lives
because people learned how to survive in
it or they didn't
um yeah i think cops are a different
breed nowadays than
what they were back then yeah they're
different especially around here i don't
know how much time you spend in florida
yeah i mean they're nice guys they're
nice guys yeah they are nice guys i mean
fair they're fair yeah they're fair
i find them um squared away
you know military-ish
more on the more on the lines of
military than you know that approach to
things you know but
you know i want you to let them let
their guard down a little bit they're
human like everybody else you know
mm-hmm
which is which is the truth i mean
tomorrow your brother's a cop you know
you know
your uncle's a couple yeah your aunt's a
cop right sorry you know
well your neighbor yeah it's not it's
not a job that i envy
i mean especially nowadays yeah with the
spotlight
shining on on everybody and all the
phones and everything well so so that's
funny because you bring the spotlight
i am i was the first advocate of course
no one listens to me because
i'm a dirty rogue [ __ ] corrupt cop i
was the first advocate be
behind every cop should wear a [ __ ]
camera
really yeah yeah every cop should wear a
camera well because they keep you honest
yeah on those moments where you because
people don't forget
human beings put these uniforms on right
um
so it keeps you honest and uh and
most times cops do the right thing most
times
like 99 percent of the time they do the
right thing i mean you
might and i liked what they did you
might not have wanted to be arrested but
it's an ugly situation in any in any
respect
if if if a patron or a perpetrator
doesn't want to get arrested
it's going to get ugly right so you're
asking
a human being to do the job of a machine
that just you know
that's doesn't really yeah cops are
humans too yeah you know you know you if
you spit in my face i do want to knock
your [ __ ] teeth out right right you
know
just as a man right so so you know
that guy's still a man he just spit in
his [ __ ] face i mean i don't know how
they do it today
he's throwing rocks and bricks and
[ __ ] urine and [ __ ] at the cops i
would
i saw a video the other day my
father-in-law
my father-in-law was like a really he he
uh he used to work for one of the big uh
this place called srt around here that
sold a lot of the uh the guns and the
body armor to
a lot of the local law enforcement
around here he showed me a video of
this guy charging a police officer
the cop shoots him at least 11 or 12
times
and the guy's still going yeah and
eventually he hits him like the 13th
time and he finally drops to his knees
yeah not done not done yet though never
seen anything like that man
[ __ ] zombie yeah but uh good luck
yeah you know being a cop dude that
means how about the scene we saw you saw
the one where the
the uh the police officer comes out of
his patrol car
the young black heavyset black girl goes
to stab a girl on the ground oh he has
to stab the girl
against the car who's just standing
there right and the cop shoots
her and he's a scumbag low-life piece of
[ __ ] right
yeah that's the problem with the
internet though that's like like i agree
that that the
the the cameras are a great thing
because it keeps you honest right
it keeps you it keeps you honest you
can't lie about what happened
also the problem is that once you throw
that into something like twitter
then it's just tribalism at its worst
you know what i mean everyone wants to
pick their like okay before i make my
before i form my opinion on this what
side am i on
well yeah well if you start out on the
side then you're really that's the
problem you're never
yeah you're gonna there's gonna be a
problem right right so you just i
like picture me i was a cop so i favor
the cops normally
but i've been arrested by police
officers okay
so i know how to be a little more
exacting and judgmental of their actions
so you know i always say that i think
i'm one of the better critics of
policing
and police work so if i'm telling you
what what's going on is correct or it's
okay
take it from a guy who's been arrested
several times okay and i didn't like any
one of them
but you know i did put my hands behind
my back eventually because i knew that i
was
submitting to being arrested for
something that i did you know i'm not
saying i was guilty of
said crimes but you know i mean
it wasn't pretty when they came to
arrest me i'll just say that much i
wanted to [ __ ] kill them
i mean yeah i i cause i they arrested me
at work the first time and then the
second time they arrested me i was out
on bail
and didn't they storm your house then
yeah yeah
and all they did was call me in that's
all they could do
the roger stone me they put the [ __ ]
helicopters to [ __ ] speed
speed boats and every [ __ ] thing else
dogs
search lights they beat your ass when
they do that they
rough you up a little bit no
i've heard a lot of stories about drug
dealers getting their ass kicked when
they get the doors beat down
i had one guy in here saying he almost
got he got they beat his head to a pulp
when they were they
uh this guy who was at ecstasy kingpin
in uh arizona
oh i mean you might get a beating yeah
whatever i don't know it whatever it's
life
they say it's a couple hard knocks here
and there what are you gonna do yeah but
if
you survived it if you if you comply
with them you well that's different yeah
you would think that
i shouldn't get my ass beat no you
shouldn't comply i agree
like 100 percent you should not get your
ass beat if you comply thank you
you're correct it should never happen do
you think a problem is a lot of people
don't was he complaining cops
huh was that gentleman complying with
him yeah i think so okay at least he
said he was all right well maybe he was
that was his story no yeah no no
and he very well could have been because
i know some guys are just so amped up
like they gotta meet justice right here
i mean dude
this is your job just do it just do it
right
have the guy say they treated me like a
gentleman so you know that
there's nothing wrong with that yeah
that's my opinion um
i used to buy them beer and [ __ ] uh
chicken
[Laughter]
i